today's topic our favorite steve harvey
oh
heather bought me her list of
requirements so let's check him out
he must be between 30 and 45 financially
stable no kids
5 10 or taller no hookups or flings
ready to settle down no roommates no
smoking
must love dessert and can't be
anti-sugar
what's the deal with the desserts well
okay that's a really important one
because
i'm the founder and ceo of my own
frosting company
and so it's an all-natural gourmet
frosting and so i make a lot of desserts
and i do a lot of you know trade shows
and making desserts so
he has to like dessert if he doesn't
like dessert it's totally a deal
what so if he doesn't like this
so my work my girl works in the bank if
i don't like numbers
it's a it's uh it's a no
how does this work like your
relationship is gonna be based
on the dessert you make on the dessert
you make
that's just the top of your beauty on
the dessert you make
one two if you get the 34
30 to 45 the chances he have kids
is bigger okay
and i better be honest with you you're
not necessarily that hard to be that
demanding
i said that but the sugar thing on top
wow that's just ridiculous
but anyway she likes what she likes but
there's some more requirements so let's
take a look at these
must be uh honest reliable sweet and
kind quick quit it romantic must love
food must pay on the first date no
flowers on the first date must be a
social drinker and must never wear
sweatpants
yeah yeah you're not even that hot for
the first side
and then you got a second sight yo wow
what
and i mean those are basics
why he can't wear sweatpants no the last
guy i dated he
we fought all the time because he wanted
to go to starbucks and sweatpants
and go to breakfast and sweatpants and
no one should be doing that did she say
starbucks
she said starbucks
and breakfast
come and see the stock box that there's
already so here
concealer starbucks so
come see the starbucks they come yeah
but it's not like it's a respectable
establishment you know what i mean
[Music]
why would i wear proper clothing when
they can't properly spell names there
yo what the [ __ ] is going on you can't
go to starbucks and sweatpants bruh
if you don't gotta work right after
wow really yeah wow
okay well we got some more requirements
but we don't have no more room
uh guys
let me get one of the pillars over here
okay must be adventurous must be humble
must be spontaneous must be a planner
can't be self-centered can't be cocky
must love dogs
i think she's trolling okay i think this
is a troll job this must be a draw
though
at which point we've fallen for the bait
hook line and sinker but on the off
chance that there really are people like
this out there i'm gonna keep watching
the video but i assume
this is a troll job can't own a dog from
a breeder can't be jealous of her dog
and can't own a cat
okay he can't be jealous of your dog so
the last guy i dated he admitted
after a few months that he was jealous
of my dog and he was kind of mean to my
dog in the beginning
and he said that i gave my dog more
attention than i gave to him
did you well
i mean my dog never fought with me
then marry your [ __ ] dog like
don't you mean marry your [ __ ] dog
[ __ ]
i mean everybody ready must be in shape
can't have six-pack can't have six-pack
abs can't be too skinny can't have a
runner's physique
can't be stronger than me can't be can't
be obsessed with sports can't be a
hunter can't own a boat can't be a gamer
can't be materialistic hold on hold on
you're gonna you're gonna get pissed off
because of the third pillar
this is the fourth pillar there's a no
there's the board
there's a board like there's one pillar
yeah another pillar
and there's a third pillar he can't want
to buy
things all the time can you talk to my
wife
probably okay let's keep going
uh much respect must respect a gloom
free diet can't be too close to family
and friends must open doors for me must
be willing to move someplace warm muscle
traveling
listen stop stop stop come okay okay
listen
um the flag is as big and red as the
dress she's wearing
huh what are you talking about she's
wearing a red flag that's what i'm
saying that's exactly what i said
that's exactly what i said you're
wearing one your
your red flag that's that's what that's
what you are that's what you is
a red flag um
only thing i could say is you're
entitled to have
all these demands because they're not
criteria's their demands
when it starts with must um
you have the right to have those
demands but you also have the right to
stay single the rest of your life
ain't nobody should be in a relationship
with you but today she's on if you find
your dude
maybe he's out there let's find out they
set her up on a date and you want to
find out
see if you're looking for a guy with all
of that yeah i don't
know that he exists no no he's got to
exist
no guy is everything please welcome
colin
how about you go out and see if you can
enjoy him and if he can enjoy you
and promise me one thing we're not
discussing the list
steve told me that i'm not gonna find a
guy that
meets all those requirements i'm
enjoying his company
he seems like a really nice normal guy
the date is going really well
it was nice to kind of converse with her
away from the lights i would like there
to be a second date
but again he lives in dc and
i'm not going to ever live in dc i have
no
desire to live in dc so what do they
call it geographically undesirable
i think that might be the case all right
well this is super
uninsightful
um what
i said it's uninsightful
it's it says steve rv when you press on
the video true
true
let's see if we can come out of this
with something um
no how do you thanks for watching
[Laughter]
i just i don't
let's say she's a caricature let's say
she's just an extreme end
by tablet one we were already saying
that's too much
so forget her other five extra set to
the list like
just her first one um was just
i don't even know if i have more than
five
man i'd be lucky to get to five i'd be
lucky to get the five two
oh no
i don't know i've never even thought of
making a list
and checking it twice and then
going back to back pages
are nice even having to write in between
each line
that red flag is coming to town
i've seen that on dating profiles too
girls talking about what they need
and they got like seven or eight things
i'm like no that's really tinder
that girl is not a caricature yeah
there's a lot of people
out there like that that are very i
don't know he was too this he was too
dead i'm not
no i'm just um
the thing that happened is like when
they have lists like that
and they go on days and like oh the guy
was nice because everything was he was
perfect but
it is something that stupid to me it
screams career
fear of commitment you're afraid you're
afraid to jump in so you give yourself a
reason you sabotage
your dating and then you blame it on not
you
it's not you it's never you right that's
on both sides
but when i see that when i see the
people that have a long list like that
and they they always find something
wrong with someone
it's like yo you think your [ __ ] don't
sting
there's this there's plenty of things
that are wrong with you look you're
nagging over some
stuff like that yeah when you're
bringing up stuff like that yeah it's
your
you have a fear of commitment it's easy
to point yeah go ahead no
it's easy to point it's easy to point
man say men i have a fear of commitment
they don't want to commit if you always
find something wrong with men
in little things like i don't like
desserts you have a fair commitment too
you translate it differently oddly
enough if she went the opposite
direction
of a lot of her points she'd actually do
a great job of finding somebody
like for example she had one point where
she's like i don't want a man with a
six-pack abs
who cares what does that make you feel
self-conscious because the fact that
he's taking really good
care of himself what if he can't be
stronger than me that's what she said
she also said that so it's just like
little stuff like we're like
he can't like sugar what if you took it
to like maybe i'll just try to date
somebody who has a diet different than
me and i'll try to be super accepting
who knows right that could be something
that you look at
right you look at someone who's like
must be a planner why don't you work
towards being more of a planner
maybe it'll make it easier for you to
find relationships what is it that you
have to try to impose so much on other
people why can't it be more stuff to
impose on others
most of my requirements you know what
they are they're just about how i don't
want you to impose things on me
i don't want to change i i i want you
like the biggest thing for me is i don't
want someone to come in and try to mold
me into their boyfriend
right like like that's like my biggest
thing my boundaries
lie around what i want for myself not
what i want from my girl my girl could
be a doctor
she could be a gender i don't give a
[ __ ] have whatever job
and type of life and hobbies that you
want that's your thing
my boundaries exist around me but she's
trying to
she got this i hate this because i've
seen this a lot in my dating life
it's like sometimes you'll meet girls
and like either they're gonna have like
a cardboard cutout
and like let's say it'll be a cardboard
cutout of like a six
three white man and then they'll take
a 510 black dude and try to stick him in
there
and try to force him in but he's too big
for some of the shapes and sizes and
he doesn't have the same length it
doesn't work
a lot of people treat their partners and
their dating experiences like that they
have a cardboard cut out
and they're like who can fit in who can
get as close as possible
when really you should just have a giant
square
right and everything outside the square
is your boundaries right
and everything inside that square is
what they can potentially be let them
fill that in
and let's see if you like what's in
there but don't try to make everyone
um fi fit the mold because one
it's it's unfair to yourself because
you're never going to be satisfied
and it's unfair to them because you're
forcing them to change who they are in
order to please you
and it's just a bad way to have
relationships that's been my experience
in dating a lot like with women that i
wanted to be in relationships with
i felt like they were always trying to
mold me into what they wanted
and i and you know like that feeling you
get in your stomach when you feel like
something in this dynamic is becoming
bad
i would get that every time and it
always made me feel uneasy and the thing
that happened is that if you have these
so much criterias and you don't want to
change them
you don't want to change because you
don't feel like you should change
that's a bit arrogant you don't feel
like you should cheat no you must have
that
no compromise you have these is
but you think you're perfect you think
you're a 10 you you shouldn't change
everybody has room for improvement
everybody
everybody but you're not willing to
change anything because you're good
that's the way you are oh that's a bit
arrogant
that's a bit arrogant on you yep it's a
bit arrogant
you you this is the way you should check
the way you
see yourself and there's a lack of
self-esteem there there's the no no
there's left
there's lack of self-awareness there
there is arrogance
there there is
all around a self-entitlement
i shouldn't be there and what do you
have to bring to the table girl
you're not that much of a catch to be
honest with you
you i i'm at best
i'm not going to comment on that but
i'll leave it to preach so we want to
hear your comments below what do you
guys think about what was just she
commented on the sis back on my
in the household how big in this day and
i can't comment on her
no show flappy arms
[Music]
oh